I want to briefly look at a statement
that the failed former president Donald
Trump made
in which he announced that he will end
crime well cool like I mean listen as I
said earlier Trump should have just
banned the virus that would have been
the simplest way to end the pandemic and
who why not it's genius right just End
crime and then you don't have to deal
with it Trump
extraordinarily swollen and very much
slurring during this wacky bizarre
statement
Joe Biden and the defund the police
Democrats have turned our once great
cities into cesspools of Bloodshed and
crime so already okay we are we're 13
seconds in but the first six seconds
were silent okay so we're seven seconds
in
Trump is already telling Endless Lies
the defund the police Democrats I still
never met them I get a few emails every
once in a while from people who go we
should defund the police
overwhelmingly what the left wants is
what I've outlined which is reform the
police retrain the police reorganize the
police
and by the way the idea of rampant crime
on average crime is down over time and a
lot of people don't want to acknowledge
this Oklahoma has a higher per capita
crime rate than New York State Oklahoma
City has a higher violent violent crime
rate per capita the New York City
but it doesn't matter okay seven seconds
it takes me a minute to tell you the
lies that have been included in that
seven second period there's never been
anything like it here's my plan to
restore Law and Order
in our cities and throughout our country
frankly first because police forces have
been gutted by democrats war on police I
will sign a record investment in hiring
retention and training for police
officers Nationwide so important this
bill will also increase vital liability
protections for officers he wants more
liability protection for officers now I
am not someone who says there should be
no special protection afforded to police
officers it is undeniable that police
officers face a certain type of risk
that people who do you know baking or
podcasting or whatever don't I
acknowledge that and I I don't think
very many people would deny that
but what we don't need are blanket
protections that make it so police don't
even consider
the consequences of their actions and so
eliminating those those minimum things
makes no sense whatsoever because the
Democrats want to take those protections
away from our police because we want
them to do their jobs and we want them
to do their jobs right you can't take
their protections away if you're going
to have them do their jobs
second to qualify for this new funding
and all other justice department grants
I will insist that local jurisdictions
return to proven Common Sense policing
measures such as stop and frisk so Trump
will require stop and frisk stop and
frisk which has been widely analyzed as
a disaster when it was used in in New
York City and in other places Trump says
not only do I recommend I will require
stop and frisk wow very simple you stop
them and you Frisk them strictly
enforcing existing gun laws against
evicted felons cracking down on the open
use of illegal drugs and cooperating
with ice to get criminal aliens off our
streets and get them out of our country
third we will go after the radical
Marxist prosecutors who are abolishing
cash bail I would be shocked to find I
mean listen might there be one
is there a judge somewhere that's a
Marxist is there a prosecutor somewhere
that is actually a Marxist
Maybe
but the idea that there are Marxist
judges and prosecutors as a matter of
common occurrence is a joke there are
like no marxists in the United States
very I mean they exist very very few
refusing to charge crimes and
surrendering our cities to Violent
criminals they have surrendered like
never before like dogs I will direct the
doj to open civil rights investigations
into radical left prosecutors officers
such as those in Chicago LA and San
Francisco to determine whether they have
illegally engaged in race-based
enforcement of the law I will also work
with Congress to give the victims of
their Marxist policies the right to sue
are you a victim of Marxism in 2023 in
the United States call now for a free
evaluation
how stupid does this sound victims of
Marxism local officials for harm and
suffering and it has been great that
they have caused if your small business
is pillaged because shoplifting goes
punished if you're brutally attacked by
a violent felon released without bail or
Bond then you will be entitled to
massive damages fourth I will order the
did Marxism touch you inappropriately
have you been damaged by it has the
labor theory of value perverted your
children call now you may be entitled to
compensation Department of Justice or
some people call it the
Department of Injustice right now and
Homeland Security dismantle every gang
Street crew and Drug Network in America
every single one of them will be
dismantled we already know where these
turf wars and Drug dens are we know who
the People Are People I'm going to
charge them and charge the culprits with
every crime that we can find I don't
know why he's screaming I genuinely
don't going to be fair but we're going
to be tough we also need the death
penalty for drug dealers so important
and I'd add to that human traffickers
human drug dealers and human traffickers
kill them get the death penalty there
you go watch it stop and stop quickly
all right so there is Trump's plan to
End crime and uh it never really makes
any sense
uh what he says it also doesn't make
sense that his right eye is almost
completely swollen shut I've still never
been able to understand that so
I didn't know it was so simple uh
compensate the victims of Marxism and uh
you will be well on your way to ending
crime so these are the by the way
this counts as policy to right Wingers
when right-wingers see this they go look
this is this isn't culture where this is
this is policy Trump will compensate the
victims of Marxism and that's a great
policy that he is proposing off the
rails completely off the rails uh we'll
have this clip and others on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the David Pacman
show we will also have this clip and
others available in Spanish on the
Spanish YouTube channel davidpackman.com
Spanish make sure you are subscribed
make sure to let your Spanish-speaking
friends relatives and neighbors know if
they want to get progressive political
commentary but they prefer it in Spanish
the place to go is davidpackman.com
Spanish we'll take a quick break and the
program continues right after this
it's a new year many of us are trying to
make new positive changes here's
something really simple that could be a
game changer our sponsor athletic greens
every day I take a scoop of ag-1 I get
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients to last
me all day long this way I just know my
nutritional bases are covered for the
entire day it has everything I want and
that's important to me rather than doing
the individual supplements and vitamins
or whatever
I don't want to do any of that okay ag1
is the simplest way to just get
everything I want for my nutritional
Foundation each day ag1 is also a great
bang for your buck you're going to end
up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and
minerals so save some money make your
life easier just a scoop of ag1 I love
the travel packs which let me take ag1
wherever I go I have the big pack of
ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below